es ist etwas grauenhaftes passiert etwas
womit man natürlich in diesem ort
überhaupt nicht gerechnet hätte jetzt um
10 uhr wird eine pressekonferenz sein
darauf hofft man sich natürlich weitere
informationen zu diesem schrecklichen
fall in norwegen es gibt so sagt auch
wilde viele offene fragen zu diesem
zeitpunkt vor allem auch zum möglichen
motiv und zum hintergrund des täters
ist
gut
in form
[Musik]
ist
ich habe die kollegen aus norwegen
gerade gefragt welche erwartungen sie an
diese pressekonferenz hat ob man wohl
etwas mehr zum hintergrund des täters
erfahren wird und sie sagte ja es gibt
viele offene fragen die wir beantwortet
haben wollen beispielsweise gab es
vorher auch schon kontakt in irgendeiner
form zur polizei also war der täter
polizeibekannt das möchte man gerne
beantwortet haben und natürlich auch zum
motiv gibt es viele offene fragen
schocken ließ
ich habe gerade noch mal gefragt der
täter ging mit pfeil und bogen vor eine
sehr ungewöhnliche wahl der waffe ob es
in norwegen der zeit irgendwelche
erkenntnisse dazu gibt gibt es bisher
nicht man weiß aber mittlerweile er
hatte mehrere waffen bei sich auch dazu
erhofft man sich natürlich auch
antworten auf der pressekonferenz wird
das senkt you very much feier teil denke
für information und
hier nach diesen ersten stimmen direkt
von vor ort aus norwegen aus kongsberg
und aus der hauptstadt oslo von unserer
journalisten kollegen wollen hier im
studio weiter sprechen über diesen ja
sehr bewegenden dramatischen fall dort
aus kransberg und das tun wir mit dem
sicherheitsexperten malte rojinski den
zu uns gekommen ist heute früh überleben
die wahl der waffe ja so spezielles in
diesem fall einen guten morgen an sie
und an unseren kollegen peter hell der
im fall an der spree weg ganz besonders
recherchiert hat eine dokumentation
darüber auch verfasst hat mit unserer
kolleginnen annika rage gemeinsam wie
oft ist dir dieser name breivik in den
vergangenen stunden immer wieder in den
kopf gekommen
ja leider eigentlich fortlaufend die
bilder die wir jetzt gesehen haben haben
einen erschreckenden charakter gleichen
charakter wie vor zehn jahren dieser
dramatische schreckliche amoklauf durch
anders breivik was vor zehn wochen eben
sich auch zum zehnten mal gejährt hat
und vom emotionalen er muss ich sagen
denkt man sofort an an dieselbe tat man
denkt oh gott was ist da schon wieder
passiert warum wieder norwegen warum
wieder wahllos menschen irgendwo
ermordet worden das hat sehr starke
parallelen
dann genau auf diesen auf diesen
informationen muss man natürlich auch
gucken wie ist die motivlage des täters
wie ist er vorgegangen das wird die
polizei natürlich jetzt alles prüfen
aber es hat sehr viel ähnlichkeiten auch
dieses gezielte bei der motivlage wie
gesagt wissen wir im aktuellen fall noch
nichts wir können da noch keine
parallelen ziehen aber möglicherweise
bei der reaktion der polizei auch bei
der reaktion der sicherheitsbehörden
wenn sie einmal und auch du peter einmal
schaut wie lief das da gestern vor ort
du weißt von spezialeinsatzkräften dort
in norwegen kennst dich mit der
polizeitaktik dort aus wie lief das
gestern in den minuten nachdem die erste
alarmmeldung eingegangen ist auch auf
erfahrung dieses falls breivik
das ist natürlich sehr schwer zu sagen
was kann man von hier aus nicht sagen
weil diese kleinstadt wir haben es ja
gehört da ist die polizeistation gerade
mal einen kilometer entfernt und 30
minuten scheint sehr lange zu sein im
üblichen ist die polizei das muss man
auch sagen gar nicht bewaffnet in
norwegen jetzt ist direkt danach auch
eine landesweite anweisung bekommen vom
innenministerium alle polizisten zu
bewaffnen landesweit eben um eventuelle
nachahmungstäter sofort stellen zu
können die alarmkette die dort eintrifft
das kann man nur spekulieren warum es so
ist warum es so lange gedauert hat es
müssen natürlich bei solchen sachen
direkt auch spezialeinheiten zugezogen
werden und die delta einhalten das ist
so eine art entschuldigung gsg9 wie bei
uns in deutschland die sind in oslo
stationiert als eine top trainierte
elite einer die eben auf geiselnahmen
terror lagen trainiert ist die brauchen
auch natürlich etwas also ich gehe davon
aus das ist eine relativ
unübersichtliche lage dann ist an
gewesen ist dass man auch erstmal wissen
muss wie viele täter sind es wer ist das
und da die tat sich auch in mehreren
stellen in dieser kleinstadt abgespielt
hat geht man natürlich erst mal von
einer großlage aus dass es mehrere täter
sein können also das dauert und ist da
zugegriffen werden kann überraschen
werden darüber auch gesprochen
die wahl der waffe sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich herrschen ski aden sie eine
einschätzung dazu was das über den täter
aussagen könnte nun die bedienung von
pfeil und bogen als als waffe erfordert
schon geschick und erfordert training
das heißt hier liegt es nahe dass der
täter eine persönliche beziehung
irgendwie dazu hatte das heißt dass er
vielleicht den diesen diesen sport
betrieben hat dass er in irgendeiner
weise
ausgebildet war oder trainiert war das
zu bedienen denn so einfach ist das
nicht also nicht jeder anfänger kann
sich freuen und bogen aus dem geschäft
greifen und dann einfach mal gezielt
auch wirklich drauf los schießen dazu
braucht eine gewisse vorbereitung und
deswegen liegt es nahe dass da irgendein
hintergrund eben war das wird es werden
sicherlich jetzt auch die die
ermittlungen zeigen ob das
in irgendeiner form hat para
militärischer ansatz war oder einfach
ein sportlicher einsatz haben diese
pfeile gesehen mitteilt feile die dort
ja auch in der wand stecken geblieben
sind das zeigt mit welcher wucht diese
pfeile geschossen werden bzw welche
geschwindigkeit und welche wucht die
auch entfalten braucht es dafür
eigentlich einen waffenschein
nein also in deutschland zum beispiel
ist so ein pfeil und bogen sind waffen
natürlich aber eigentlich unter dass das
waffenrecht das heißt also eine
erlaubnisfreie waffen ähnlich denke ich
mal wird auch in norwegen sein aber es
ist natürlich eine gefährliche waffe
also beim sportlichen bogenschießen ist
so die geschwindigkeit die abschuss
geschwindigkeit von einem pfeil bei 100
meter die sekunde
es ist schon ganz ordentlich das ist
nicht so viel wie eine pistolenkugel die
ist etwa dreimal so schnell eine
gewehrkugel ist acht bis neun mal so
schnell aber das ist natürlich schon
wenn man sich überlegt 100 meter in
einer sekunde und die kinetik die
dahinter steckt dass auch beachtlich und
man kann mit modernen
bögen auch ziemlich präzise zielen mit
dem recurve recurvebogen da gibt es
zielvorrichtung dran stabilisatoren etc
da kann man dann schon welche
entfernungen etwa man kann da auf 30 50
70 meter treffen es gibt disziplin die
da geht es um 80 90 meter aber im grunde
kann man natürlich da entsprechend auf
einige distanz dann auch personen oder
ziele insgesamt treffen man braucht dann
natürlich ein bisschen ruhe für das
heißt das ist ja sind die das sind diese
fehler haben wir ganz kurz dazwischen
gehen darf er als kinder die wie gesagt
da in der haus waren steckengeblieben
sind nach diesem schrecklichen blut wenn
die damit 100 meter die sekunde also gut
300 stundenkilometern ankommen das
allein bringt eine gewisse gnädig mit
sich und sie sehen ja daran wie die da
in einer hauswand stecken bleiben wie
das auch in anderen zielen passieren
kann sie sagten auch gerade dafür
brauchen wir ein bisschen ruhe bisschen
zeit natürlich ist so eine waffe nicht
so schnell bedienen war wie eine schuss
feuerwaffe beispielsweise also man
braucht dafür ja was können sie
irgendetwas sagen was das darüber auch
über die fertigkeiten dieses täters aus
sagt ist es eigentlich fast
auszuschließen dass derjenige nicht
irgendwie in einer form darauf trainiert
war würde einem laien das überhaupt
gelingen wir wissen nicht auf welche
distanz was passiert ist ja wenn jetzt
der täter die kennen die umstände noch
nicht da werden wir jetzt in einer
stunde hoffentlich ein bisschen mehr
erfahren oder auch in den nächsten tagen
wird ja immer mehr rauskommen es kann
natürlich sein dass er in einer
bestimmten situation auf eine sehr kurze
distanz da einfach aus irgendeiner art
asche diesem bogen gezogen hat und dann
überraschend weil natürlich niemand mit
so einer art von waffe auch rechnet
schon gar nicht in dieser kleinstadt
dann in kurzer zeit in einem begrenzten
raum zb ist die rede war von einem
supermarkt
weiß wie man weiß ich etwas drin oder
davor aber in einem supermarkt haben wir
natürlich noch viel kürzere distanzen da
gibt es vielleicht die möglichkeit auch
menschen in die in irgendeiner ecke zu
drängen und dann entsprechend halt zu
zielen und dann mit einem
einschüchterungsversuch an einem ort zu
belassen und dann halt innerhalb von 10
20 30 sekunden 23 feile oder so
abzuschließen soll sich tatsächlich auch
in diesem korb supermarkt dort in dieser
kleinen stadt kongsberg abgespielt haben
augenzeugen am gestrigen abend noch
davon berichtet dass der menschen raus
gelaufen sein mit pfeilen tatsächlich im
rücken stecken peter hell wir haben
gerade die aktuelle nachrichtenlage
nochmal geschildert hier werden unsere
sendung ist die nachricht rein gekommen
dass der täter gestanden hat
mittlerweile was weißt du wenn du
unseren zuschauern noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen kannst aktuell über
diesen mann also wir wissen dass es sich
um einen 37 jährigen mann aus dänemark
handel soll staatsangehörigkeit dänisch
was wir auch gehört haben ist dass er
sich wohl ergeben hat dass er wohl noch
eine weitere waffe bei sich getragen
haben soll nach unseren informationen
soll es sich dabei um ein messer
gehandelt haben die polizei soll ein
warnschuss abgegeben haben daraufhin
muss er sich oder soll er sich wohl
ergeben haben also das alles deutet
darauf hin dass solche menschen die in
so einer amok situation sind das alles
sehr geplant haben und abend mit auch
rechnen dass sie festgenommen werden was
sich jetzt abspielt in der polizei oder
abgespielt hat gestern abend ist extrem
wichtig für die für die behörden weil
nach wie vor zählt wie ist die lage gibt
es mehrere täter ist die tat geplant hat
so ein täter eventuell das kann man
abgleich mit breivik eventuell noch
sprengsätze versteckt wie ist die wahl
der opfer von statten gegangen sind die
gezielt ausgesucht worden oder waren das
zufallsopfer
dann muss man sich psychologisch auch in
die beamten muss man erklären wie gehe
ich an so ein täter dann das heißt
behandle ich ihn schroff versuche ich
ganz schnell eben aufgrund der notlage
heraus zu finden weitere informationen
oder versuche ich es sanft zu machen bei
breivik haben sie es gemacht sehr sanft
weil sie wissen wollten sie wollten ihn
nicht verschrecken das hat vielleicht
hier auch stattgefunden also erstmal das
wichtigste ist erst mal die erstaufnahme
dass ich weiß warum gibt es weitere
täter gibt es ist die gefahrenlage
gebannt also wir wissen dass das
städtchen noch abgesperrt die suchen
noch nach weiteren waffen etc also das
ist noch eine sehr
variable situation
weitere schinski und unser kollege peter
hell vielen herzlichen dank für ihren
für euren besuch hier im studio mit
neuesten informationen zu dem
schrecklichen fall in kongsberg in
norwegen er wo ein mann fünf menschen
mit pfeil und bogen getötet hat und zwei
weitere menschen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
verletzt hat und es gibt jetzt auch neue
erkenntnisse in dem fall ja aktuell
hören wir zu all dem was peter uns
gerade ganz aktuell geschildert hat dass
der mann eine gewisse medizinische
vorgeschichte haben soll also mehrfach
mit den norwegischen gesundheitsbehörden
in kontakt gewesen sein soll worum es
sich daher gehandelt haben könnte ist
derzeit noch nicht bekannt er soll aber
auch polizeibekannt gewesen sein also
das sind die aktuellen nachrichten die
er zum minütlich hier ein tröpfeln auch
während unserer sendung peter als gerade
schon gesagt das wird eine
pressekonferenz geben in rund 40 minuten
dort in norwegen im süden norwegen sind
kongsberg in dieser stadt die 80
kilometer entfernt ist von oslo und auf
diese pressekonferenz schauen wir
natürlich gleich und sie hören von uns
sobald es dort neue entwicklungen gibt
da wir nach dieser schrecklichen bluttat
vom gestrigen frühen abend gegen 18 uhr
30 das ja alles passiert den kongsberg
ein mann zieht mit pfeil und bogen durch
eine kleinstadt und ermordet dort fünf
menschen und verletzt mindestens zwei
weitere schwer
[Musik]